hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 3
video great great episode so much WTF
there was so much blood you think they
were doing an episode of Torchwood I
realized some of you probably have no
idea what Torchwood is he was a really
big Doctor Who spin-off starring John
Barrowman
as Captain Jack Harkness he was immortal
people stole his blood for a long time
to heal themselves it was really freaky
but tonight's episode of legends of
tomorrow was really more Eyes Wide Shut
if you guys are Stanley Kubrick fans
such a weird film but so awesome so just
careful for spoilers from episode 3 if
you haven't seen it yet let's start with
top 5 WTF and then I'll explain some
Easter eggs there's some really big
stuff coming to that I'll talk about at
the end of the video number 5 I've seen
men of steel fail and Dark Knight's fall
this is a line from the trailer a lot of
you are asking me wait does this mean
the Batman and Superman exists well we
already know that Supergirl is now part
of the arrowverse Superman has cameoed
on that show arrow took a really big
shot at Barbara Gordon last week so that
kind of means the Batman characters
exist unofficially so yeah you could
totally say that he's talking about
Batman and Superman but it's intended to
be very tongue-in-cheek the setup for
the episode actually comes from Rachel
Ghul strike at your enemy's heart so
Canaries like let's go cut off his bank
funds mr. al Ghul sounds like quite the
poet number 4 WTF the Hawkgirl B story
she's still got shards of vandal
savage's dagger left in her from episode
2 they got to get it out so it's
Fantastic Voyage Adam and the funny
thing is is that even though they're in
the 70s in this episode again they're in
the same time period as they were in
last week's episode Fantastic Voyage is
a 60s movie but as much as it's about
fixing Kendra Adam has to fix his level
of confidence so Martin Stein just
amazingly bullshit's him into helping
Kendra again it all goes great she
finally wakes up and we actually find
out that she has like the weird type of
psychic connection to hawk man's body in
the way that firestorm is connected like
one can sense when the others in trouble
so even though Hawk man's dead she still
has this connection to his body so if an
old savage were to try and do something
with it no matter where he is she would
probably sense it number 2 3 WTF captain
cold and heatwave encouraged Jax to help
them steal the Maximilian emerald I know
everybody wondered ever since the
trailer dropped because this was in the
trailer one
did this was kryptonite no it's just a
giant emerald just worth crazy money
captain cold wants to change his past
but him at his childhood home was
actually probably my favorite moment so
I'll talk about that in a second number
two WTF legends of Eyes Wide Shut
so have you never seen eyes wide shut it
was Stanley Kubrick's last big movie
before he died it was one of the weirder
ones but like most Stanley Kubrick films
it's really good but it has all this
weird imagery in it so the minute they
opened the doors and you see this crazy
secret society holding what looks like
it's going to be this crazy orgy all I
could think about was Eyes Wide Shut
and then like a couple minutes later
when heatwave busts in he actually says
Eyes Wide Shut I didn't feel like he
needed to do that but I was like oh my
god they actually meant to do that one
of my favorite things is spotting really
big references like that when they pay
homage to really classic really big
things they're actually doing a
magnificent 7 episode I think it's
called the Magnificent 8 is actually the
Jonah Hex episode and even earlier in
the episode when they're in rip hunters
office there's a bunch of Easter eggs in
there some of those are from characters
that we're gonna see show up on the show
like we're gonna see a version of
Sandman we see this Jonah Hex poster
he's showing up I'll talk more about the
characters that are coming when we get
closer to their episodes Jonah Hex is
just one of the first really really big
ones so the literal interpretation here
is that Vandal Savage can use hawk man's
blood to extend the lives of normal
people by about a hundred years as he
explains it so that's why when stabby
Serra is stabbing the [ __ ] out of this
henchman he doesn't die even though she
stabbed him like 2030 times you could
also think of Vandal Savage is using the
blood as a band-aid like he's already a
mortal he doesn't need the blood to be
immortal he absorbed Hawk man's life
force in the last episode but he can
still take in extra power I'm sure if he
ate his body that would work too but
they probably don't want to get too
graphic in the episode because this is
airing on the CW it's not like HBO but
really the biggest part of this scene
you know in addition to being super WTF
like what are they gonna have an orgy of
blood after they're done with Hawk man's
body what would have happened if they
hadn't a busted in but the important
thing is the way it book ends rip
hunter's relationship with Vandal Savage
I love the way they added that layer of
complexity like he already went back and
tried to kill him but couldn't finish
the job just because he's not a killer
so Vandal Savage in the past ended up
canonizing rip hunter is
mythical bad figure in his story but
Hawkgirl still has to be the one to kill
Vandal Savage she has the deepest
connection to him she and Carter and if
you're confused about the timeline this
seemed like some sort of circular loop
where Vandal Savage kills rip hunters
family so he goes back in time tries to
kill him Vandal Savage learns about rip
hunter and then in the future knows to
kill his family so you're like what
happened during the first sequence of
events did Vandal Savage originally kill
his family in a different way did he
change the past by making something
different it really just kind of syncs
up with the idea of Captain Cold
trying to change his timeline and being
unsuccessful they explained it on the
flash really well during season 1 if you
try to change the timeline to avoid some
really bad event time itself will find a
way to replace that event with something
just as bad if not worse
speaking of which on to my number one
WTF best moment in the episode Captain
Cold talking to his childhood self you
could just see Wentworth Miller here
crying the whole time without tears
coming down his face
like the minute he walks into his
childhood home he tries to touch the
bottle but he pulls his hand back he
looks at the teddy bear and suddenly you
can see his heart breaking inside his
chest so he sees his younger self gives
him the speech and even though he was
unsuccessful with his father trying to
change his future I do think his speech
to his childhood self had an effect
never let anyone hurt you up here never
let anyone hurt you in here if he wasn't
already Captain Cold should be your
favorite character on this show after
this episode if he isn't I don't know
what's wrong now Sarah had great moments
of pathos too like she was experiencing
bloodlust I know there was some
confusion about that people were like
wait didn't Constantine cure her of that
when he rebound her soul to her body no
apparently she still has bloodlust just
like Thea I'm actually really happy
about that because each of the
characters needs to have their own
internal problems that they're dealing
with
along with these external problems it
just makes it that much more interesting
so let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
did you actually start crying during
this scene it's okay no judging here and
here's the really awesome stuff that you
guys need to freak out about what do
king shark vixen in a one-armed Oliver
Queen all have in common they are all
going to be dropping the same week in a
couple weeks starting on
February 23rd the flash is doing its
king shark episode arrow is doing its
vixen episode the next night and then
the night after that legends of tomorrow
is doing its old Oliver Queen episode
the title that's actually Star City 2046
they're gonna be going to a future where
Oliver has one arm he's really old
we're gonna meet connor hawke it is
going to be freaking awesome giveaway
time though congratulations to Niko 7 1
3 you win this week's reverse flash ring
please private message me on the back
end of my channel for details there will
be a new round of the giveaway next week
and because it's the Super Bowl this
weekend I'll be doing some DC movie
videos so Suicide Squad Batman V
Superman related stuff there'll be a
whole bunch of Marvel stuff - Captain
America civil war trailer Sunday I'm
gonna be posting a crap ton of trailer
videos it's gonna be so awesome as you
guys probably know flash and Supergirl
are gonna have a crossover episode I
just posted a big video about that you
can click here to learn all about what's
going on with that and you can click
here for my arrow and flash videos from
this week thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you